explain to me why the single motherhood  rate in the black community jumped from  20 to 70 percent in the same course of  time that the civil rights movement has  made such tremendous strides is america  more racist now than it was in 1960 and  if it is please explain to me how that  happened what do you think of that i  think we look for different things so as  time goes forward especially um  comparing like if racism was then in  racism now it's like it can present  itself in different ways and also um i  hope that no one can deny that america  was founded on racism being that  africans were enslaved and brought over  here to literally build america and do  different works after slavery  different things enacted to  like because slavery was legal then but  they enacted different things that were  legal so that they could still have  different forms of whatever they were  wanting to do